hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agent Carter episode 5 video
it was creepy in the best possible way I
think I already mentioned the Black
Widow stuff in last week's video I'm
always happy to see the Howling
Commandos again is so much fun remember
Nick Fury was a howling commando and
Tripps father trip from agents of shield
ok so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet starting
with top five moments number five
flashback to Black Widow school if it
wasn't totally clear from the way they
cut the episode from the edits the
person we saw in the flashback that
killed her friend that was probably
dotty how awesome is it that they played
that Snow White clip to teach them how
to be super waspy housewives
every time we see Dottie from now on is
just gonna be that much more fun Dottie
with her crazy eyes there's no white
thing actually reminded me that Disney
owns Marvel so they get to use Disney IP
or it's at least is a lot easier for
them to that's why we had the Pinocchio
song on top of the Avengers trailer the
really interesting thing about this
Black Widow school is that they implied
that it's tied to Leviathan Leviathan is
a Russian organization but in the comics
the Black Widow program is more of a KGB
thing so either they're changing that
from the comics or they're gonna tie
Leviathan to the Russian government
somehow for now it seems like they're a
splinter group like Hydra was with the
Nazi Party Hydra was born out of the
Nazi Party
but then Red Skull took them in like a
completely different direction moving
that's number four welcome back Howlin
commandoes as much fun as it was seeing
all the Howling Commandos back this is
really important for Peggy's
relationship with agent Thompson he gets
to experience her and another peer group
that actually respects her that's why
you can see dum-dum Dugan giving her all
those funny looks whenever agent
Thompson was being super misogynistic at
least before Peggy saved him if you ever
wonder what the Howling Commandos are up
to normally they're just like a normal
military regiment they got the name the
Hallett commandos just because they're
super badass so they're still subject to
the orders of the military so they just
go over ever they're sent based on the
relationship between the military and
the SSR right now I don't know if we're
gonna see them again before the finale
because it sounds like the military
doesn't want to have anything to do with
this project havoc stuff moving on to
number three project havoc explained so
we finally found out what's going on at
the battle of finow what probably
happened is start designed a device for
the military as part of his R&D contract
that became project havoc the military
tested it it killed a whole bunch of
people stark out pissed because they
wanted to use it as a weapon and he
didn't think it should be used that way
that's probably what the falling-out was
about the reason he punched the general
it was like it was never planned to be a
weapon it was designed as something else
for some other function and ended up
causing this huge massacre I'm inclined
to believe dr. ivchenko the engineer
that they stole the plans from Stark
start didn't given to him Thompson is
still trying to cast him down on it
I wondered after that explanation if
they were gonna be like okay well Stark
has nothing to do with it now so we're
gonna get off this case I guess that's
not gonna happen I guess Starks not
totally off the hook yet it's totally
possible that someone close to Stark got
ahold of the plans and gave them to
Leviathan if you look at the description
for episode six for next week's episode
it just says Peggy finds out the danger
is closer to home than she thought it
makes it sound like the villain like the
true villain of the series is gonna be
someone we've already met I know I want
to believe it's Ray wisest character
just because he typically plays really
big bad evil characters but it could
totally be someone we don't expect of
all the characters that it could be of
all the Russian characters it could be
Vanko is at the top of the list but I
don't know necessarily that it's him
I haven't seen a lot of other evidence
playing to him yet you guys can let me
know who you think it might be that the
enemy that's closer to home so to speak
we're about halfway through the series
so we're getting ready for like the
third act twist that's usually what you
see before the final act of a series
they reveal who the villain is one of
the big complaints against agent Carter
right now is that there really is no
clear villain
I mean Leviathan is arguably the
villainous organization but we don't
have a face to put that name on yet
moving on to number two agent Sousa
figures out who Peggy is it was a little
unclear from all the detective work he
did it seems like he actually did figure
out who Peggy was he just matched up the
bullet wounds and Peggy's records in
that picture he has but in the
description for next week's episode it
says that he's still trying to figure it
out I guess he's just looking for
definitive evidence or he's going to
confront Peggy with the evidence it
seems pretty clear based on the way they
keep throwing those two characters
together that he's going to help Peggy
but not until he confronts her about all
the stark stuff she's been doing so
they'll have it out and then he'll ply
start helping her from the inside and
yes I think based on the moments that
they're sharing that
is going to be the man she ends up
marrying it may have been in Winter
Soldier but I think Captain America
himself said that he saved Peggy's
husband during the war I don't I don't
remember if Seuss's revealed that if
Captain America is the one that saved
him he lost his leg but he said he was
injured and then just woke up in a
hospital so someone saved them I feel
like it's gonna be Captain America it'll
be like the big surprise twist you guys
can let me know what you think about his
character but I feel like right now
there's not much going on with him he
only exists inside this mission to find
out who Peggy is and my number one
moment
Dottie gets super creepy and Peggy's
room don't you just wonder after she sat
down at that mirror and spoke in that
creepy Peggy voice if she was gonna try
to assume Peggy's identity at some point
maybe that's actually how agent Sousa is
gonna help maybe he'll recognize Dottie
in the SSR and take her down there
really leaning on this black widow theme
with Dottie and if you remember in
Winter Soldier part of black widows mo
was to take on other people's identity
she had the super face tech where she
could literally mimic the faces of other
people but I feel like daddy's going to
do her 1940s version of that so here's
my big question for you guys do you
think the Dottie
is going to try and masquerade as Peggy
and who do you think it is that's
connected to Leviathan that stole those
plans from Stark right now my top
candidate is still ray wisest character
I think it'll be a bigger twist than
that and I'm actually I used to think it
might be agent Thompson but after that
moment he shared with Peggy he just got
way more human like he admitted to her
yeah I killed all these innocent people
that were waving the white flag
I don't know necessarily that the
Leviathan person will be someone from
inside the SSR like it's not gonna turn
out to be agent Dooley but I do think
it's gonna be someone we've already met
just to mention a few the Easter eggs I
saw in the episode so whenever Peggy is
moving down the stairs in that Leviathan
base or the Black Widow school it
actually reminded me of the scene in the
Avengers 2 trailer with Captain America
infiltrating the Hydra base most of the
time the references I see an agent
Carter are references to the original
Captain America movie just because they
take place in the same time period but
every once in a while I wonder if
they're trying to tie things to the
future Marvel films and the friend that
dr. ivchenko killed he had the Russian
friend that was in that prison with him
I feel like he was an inhuman I feel
like that's what he meant when he was
talking about the way he sees the world
is different from the rest of us I was
real
hoping we get to see him use his ability
so something really cool to look forward
to I feel like we're gonna get to see
havoc in a future episode we'll get to
see the weapon go off again I feel like
they wouldn't spend all that time
talking about it and then not show it to
us so be sure to subscribe to get next
week's episode I know it's been a little
while since I've done a Marvel movie
video but I just did the daredevil
trailer if you haven't seen it yet you
can actually click here to watch it and
you can click here to catch up on air on
the flash from this week thank you so
much watching so let's all high-five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you